[Music]
the imitation technique why it's key to
learning languages
[Music]
did you know that if you mimic someone's
accent you'll be able to better
understand what they say
playwright george bernard shaw explains
that connection between learning and
imitation
as such
imitation is not just the sincerest form
of flattery it's the sincerest form of
learning
this is what psychologists at the uk's
university of manchester and holland's
redbound university discovered in a
study in 2010 the results showed that
learning through imitation
imitating the person you're talking to
helps your speech comprehension
so for language learners this imitation
learning technique means it's best to
practice your conversational skills with
a native speaker
imitation speeds up learning
in the 1970s american psychologist
andrew meltzov
identified so-called social learning
where people or animals observe and then
copy their companions
imitation accelerates learning and
multiplies learning opportunities he
noted it is faster than individual
discovery it is safer than individual
discovery and safer than learning by
trial and error
practice talking with a native speaker
so if you want to learn a new language
don't just study books
employ the imitation technique by making
contact with native speakers to set up a
language exchange
whether you're looking to learn a few
british english idioms or brush up on
some essential spanish phrases you'll
learn have fun and make new friends all
at the same time
hot tip for learning even faster if you
want to speed up the language learning
process
don't simply imitate your partner's way
of speaking accent or intonation try to
use this imitation technique for their
hand gestures and facial expressions too
not only will you sound like a native
speaker you'll also act like one there
are so many benefits to learning a
language like this as well as having a
great time and enjoying interesting
conversations you'll practice your
observation and socializing skills
tell us what you think what languages
have you learned by interacting with
native speakers what extra benefits have
you found and do you have any tips for
successful conversations want to learn a
language by having real-life
conversations with native speakers start
learning with busu for free today
[Music]
the emotional rollercoaster of language
learning
you've just decided to learn a language
and you are pumped
we're excited for you but
we also feel the need to warn you
learning a language can be a bit of an
emotional rollercoaster
stage one
so excited
you're going to learn spanish and
impress your boss you're going to learn
arabic so you can finally speak to your
husband's family you're going to laugh
along when the ladies at the nails alone
make fun of you in chinese
because the joke will finally be on them
right
yes you're super excited right now it's
all going to be so much fun
stage 2
very confident
you've picked up some study materials
enrolled in a class harassed every
brazilian looking person in a 12 block
radius to practice the 10 words you know
in portuguese
it's new it's fun it's exciting you're
going to be fluent in no time
stage 3
moderately less confident but still
determined
you've made it past the first lesson and
all of the pleasantries are over
no more bonjour a lot more uh
under
verb conjugations you feel so close
understanding all these new concepts but
you just keep getting stuck
stage four
struggling
what is that letter am i saying it this
right
am i saying it right
okay so speaking this is a little more
difficult than expected you may or may
not have hugged a logi on your cat while
trying to roll your arse but he'll get
over it
stage five paralyzing self-doubt well
now it's just ridiculous you know a few
hundred words and you can ask for more
bread please so you don't really need to
know anything else anyway right
subjunctive mode
genitive case ain't nobody got time for
that
stage six
regret wait what was the word for bread
i shouldn't have quit learning languages
are awesome what was i thinking
stage seven
renewed determination
jump back to stage one
remember how totally fun and interesting
this language is remember that you want
to tell your mother-in-law that you
don't actually like her cooking in
german
that's right get motivated again find
some new resources to make things fun
watch funny youtube videos in italian
read the harry potter novels translated
into dutch they were written for a 14
year old you don't care nothing can stop
you now stage 8
victory
you just had a conversation in another
language
and they understood that's right your
thai food order came out right
and it
was delicious then of course you try to
ask the waiter for the check and
accidentally ask for his phone number
but whatever you're conquering a new
language and it's awesome
[Music]
[Music]
you